greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by Fuji Sports Fergie's rash guards mats
whatever the [ __ ] you need in your life
Fuji Sports is there I just saw the mats
up the Joe Rogan's gym they were
tremendous and as far as the guys are
concerned you know me bro
I'm two rebuilds people try to pull they
tug and that [ __ ] G is still [ __ ]
tougher than that I don't care which one
you get whether you get the lightweight
ones to separate O's the element they're
the best gear out there like I said me I
go with the separator but if you like it
go to a checkout church and get 10% off
Fuji Sports calm checkout church and get
10% off a beautifully delivered right to
your home number two if you're doing
that gear you need some supplements
that's where honor comes in
[ __ ] whether it's the shroom
tech sport or the shroom tech immuned
which lien doesn't take that's why he's
got bronchitis every 90 [ __ ] days
you'll be tip-top Magoo eat some ass
somehow for brain and who's better than
you again on the way out check out on it
and what do you person search CH you are
CH and get 10% off and the goods get the
living right to your [ __ ] house who's
better than you take this [ __ ]
meal leak there you have it a little
Michael Shang the old [ __ ] school
feed on uncle Joey you got my [ __ ]
sidekick the Flying Jew eating his
little Jew cough drops he got like ten
bags for [ __ ] two hours at CVS y'all
can't get the Lutins
you know I'm saying vixx they've been
around since even [ __ ] Jesus took
vixx when she left
Vicks VapoRub on your chest you do a
couple bong hits you want put so big
they blow up on my chest I mean not
really
I don't do that type of [ __ ] you got the
wrong [ __ ] guy go hang out with your
little buddies over there North
Hollywood well they got the movie
screens a guy's [ __ ] I'm sure you'll
find somebody to rub some vapor rub on
your ass an you little [ __ ] and then
they'll stick that dick in it and it's
all over but the show that's old-school
[ __ ] when they put vaseline around
huh
when they use Vicks VapoRub and they
stick their [ __ ] dick in it that's
called [ __ ] the dick of debt
I don't know fired that dick anyway it
was a great week I want to thank Dean
dour
pulling me out of the show at the Avalon
with Nikki Sixx and Rudy Sarzo and the
guy from anthrax and it was just a great
time but I learned something that night
number one I want up there and I rest
through my material but that's not what
I learned I learned that the last
[ __ ] three years I've been going
through something don't know what it is
it's not a midlife crisis it's not
something has been missing you know I've
added working out I try to you know get
involved in my daughter's life and I got
the podcast in the road but the other
night when I was at that show something
hit me that we had discussed on the
podcast about a year and a half ago Rudy
and I didn't it's not that I didn't buy
into it it's not even think it was that
important and that's the element of live
music I really listen man what we did
growing up in North Bergen was go to
concerts at Madison Square Garden when
these guys call when villo or [ __ ]
tell me the Teamster or these guys we
went to every were blessed to have the
opportunity go to a lot of shows man I
mean I went to see everybody from Kenny
Rogers to took the [ __ ] I am made and
I didn't give a [ __ ] and I would go and
it wasn't something happened like in the
mid-eighties where I don't know I don't
know what happened I became a criminal
and I didn't think the live shows are
that important anymore I mean I had
friends that live for that [ __ ] when the
people had that witness no masks when I
first moved to Snowmass you work Monday
through Friday and Saturday morning in
the middle of the night you left for
Colorado Springs or Denver or you know
of Fort Collins and you catch a band
live you know these guys travel and I
think I did it one or two times with
them I just you know I worked hard I
didn't have I couldn't afford that [ __ ]
no more it was either between the blow
and rent or [ __ ] going to the spring
was and watching a band then these guys
like 19 of them lived in a two-bedroom
apartment and they had moved to Colorado
just to ski you know and they all had
two jobs they all worked on the mountain
times they get a free ski pass and then
they've all worked at restaurants of
bartending or security at hotels or in
hotels at night all of them so well they
were all there and it was the weirdest
thing 19 people in a two-bedroom
sleeping bags everywhere you know guys
everywhere in that like three girls that
lived there from Minneapolis they were
all from Mankato Minnesota and it was
just interesting how these guys limit
they and they partied during the week if
you want up Danny tonight any night of
the week you can find somebody awake in
the corner [ __ ] smoking we there was
the weirdest [ __ ] apartment I ever
saw nobody cooked there it was clean it
was spotless but it was nineteen guys
living up there in three rooms basically
just cuz they wanted to party the whole
rest of the time well they figured at
that time rent was cheap as it was this
is 83 84 got it and they wanted to get
the most out of life and they felt that
the home living didn't really matter so
that's what they [ __ ] did but anyway
well I was at that show that night I did
the show and then what Dean did was he
had every body switch up so one song it
would be anthrax and this other guy and
the drummer from the Black Crowes and
then the next three songs would be Marin
will have to congratulate did a [ __ ]
great job on the guitar on down payment
blues they they they did little little
on the edgy side edgier side but what
was really weird was Dean del Rey how
much I thought about Dean since that
night you know every [ __ ] day I wake
up to six or seven messages on Facebook
and I answer them you know as much as I
can but a little six or seven messages
it's three guys would think that pulling
the wool over my eyes
you know they want this they ask for
that they want this you know you have to
understand that I'm out there at night I
have my head to the grind like
else's who's a comic and what I don't
hear your name and I hear you making
requests and stuff like that you're
cutting corners in my world and there's
nothing that bothers me more than guys
that think they can cut corners on my
expense I'm the type of guy that if I
see you're hustling I will give you any
opportunity or do anything for you in
the world but if I don't know you and I
don't know if you're hustling I don't
know what the [ __ ] you doing and you
just hit me up demanding stuff that's
not right you know I have friends here
D'Agostino Kate Quigley [ __ ] Lee I
got ten guys that I know that are close
to me so they're out seven nights a week
week after week you know I see them
tweeting I see them facebooking I see
them replying to messages I see these
people working you know they have a
podcast or always on time with their
podcast and these guys are in selling
out arenas and you don't know them and
you don't need to know them the most
important thing is that they're working
they work constantly listen well
yesterday we got off we got out the car
picked me and Dean up at 4:15 in the
[ __ ] morning we basically went to bed
and [ __ ] 12:30 we both got on the
plane I fell asleep for an hour you
remember falling asleep I got up and
went home I picked up my daughter and my
wife went out to breakfast and then I
went home and I had a fall asleep for a
few hours I got up I had to do paperwork
and I had some bunch of email [ __ ] like
that in the two days that I was gone
I hadn't prepped this week and then you
know I just stayed in with the family
last night that when I were mercy
yesterday in the afternoon we were
frozen yogurt and we stopped at this
other place today I think of the crypto
therapy with me she watched me froze she
took pictures she couldn't believe there
was snow in there so not Dean Dean was
talking waking up he was getting home to
to go home to take a nap to wake up to
go to
[ __ ] spots last night and tonight he's
got three [ __ ] spots you know Deena's
in the name Dean isn't something bleep
but Dean don't stop he moved to
Hollywood so he could walk to the club's
so he can have easier access to the club
so he can do spots every month you know
I see Dean when if you went to this show
I applaud with you but you also saw what
Dean put together he put together a
great comedy and he put together a great
band all by himself
he didn't bother anybody he didn't
[ __ ] you know he asked him out right
and I respect that that gets my respect
I'm a huge way because there's so many
people who are confused that you think
that you're gonna take a shortcut your
life is gonna change and guess what I
used to be the same - and I got burnt
three or four times and I stopped
shortcutted I realized that the main
goal of a comedian is to be that the
funniest person he could be when I came
out here I booked a pilot LEM was a
big-time commercial but one night I got
my life [ __ ] I got the [ __ ] kicked out
of me at the improv in between NICTA - I
licked Apollo and Doug stay home and
I'll never believe that that night I
remember wanting to leave in the middle
night just to disappear on the road to
become a been atomic like I took any
gigs I could for two years on the road
from 98 to 2001 I did every [ __ ] [ __ ]
gig hall I could because I knew the
payoff was gonna be funny it wasn't
about the movies it wasn't about the TV
and that's where I see the biggest Fault
in this town is with comedians that they
do comedy for five or six years they
kind of get good on doesn't get a show
and they stop doing comedy the show ends
now they can't get work and they want to
fall back on Tommy but this six years
behind because they never thought about
Tommy those six years you always
continue getting onstage
I always knew that no matter what if I
kept getting on stage I'd eventually be
funny that's the [ __ ] final result of
it the more you get on stage and put
yourself in uncomfortable situations the
funny you'll become you know Kate went
to New York Jersey the stress factory
and tonight she's in helium that's like
one of the toughest [ __ ] clubs that's
Philadelphia well you have to bring it
and you know what people [ __ ] about
kpop I bump up my pot but let me tell
you something and come tell you how
people [ __ ] about Kate that my wife
went out one night with Felicia to a
comedy club and a comic said something
to my wife and my wife came home and
said like what and I go listen to me I
go for every woman that cries about and
that get inspired to accomplished or
doesn't give them spots though it's 22
Sarah Tiana's and Kate Quigley's and
Esther cools thought I write every night
[ __ ] fighting when you see him
they're not bitching at all about
anything they just telling you that they
came from doing two spots and they came
to a County store to see if they can get
on such and such as belly room show
they're not complaining to me at all I
give those women's [ __ ] tons of
credit it's the women that come up to me
and I can't believe you're still doing
spots at the store because they don't
give spots to women look let me tell you
some it see sure was a woman then she
sure gave out [ __ ] spots the woman
every night if I saw the schedules from
when I first started I still have him at
the [ __ ] house I got 20 schedules
from when I started I went on all this
[ __ ] started talking people women
started talking about the store I went
back and looked at those schedules it
was always the same three women a night
two women late that's sitting there
going it was like whatever that's why I
gave I give Kate Quigley and Sarah Tiana
and the women I put on my podcast the
respective I do because when I see them
they're not looking for a handout
they're out there [ __ ] banging it out
and that's the most important thing to
me in the [ __ ] world will I see you
so before you come up on Facebook and
say to me
can you do this so can I do that or can
i I don't even [ __ ] know you I don't
even know you
how can you do something like that put
me in that type position and then if I
say no I'm supposed to feel like a
[ __ ] bad person
that's not right to me either and even
if you did know them you can't either
that's not enough to put you on listen I
know a thousand people who I can put on
this [ __ ] podcast that are out there
working hard every day I think about
those people constantly because I want
to put them on when I can get the most
out of them do you understand I'm trying
to say to you I want to get the mom
before something that they doing is
blowing up or they're in the process of
blowing up I could put a certain comics
on here every [ __ ] day if I wanted to
but what's the use they're not on
Twitter they're not on Facebook they're
not hustling it's a waste of a [ __ ]
guest because whatever they're saying is
[ __ ] they're just trying to [ __ ]
get on here because they think it's a
one-hit Pony the way people think that
if you get on Rogen one time your life
is gonna change no it's how you act
during Roget after opened that makes the
decision whatever product you're selling
or whatever proof yo whatever point
you're trying to prove or whatever harm
you're trying to sell that's what you
get the opportunity I'm Rogan but most
people think oh wow I just go on some of
these podcasts in my life will [ __ ]
change that's a horrible way of looking
at things what hi was coming up it was a
view what I let him in or Leno your life
would [ __ ] change I never [ __ ]
emailed them I knew I'd never get on
those shows because I'm not CBS a [ __ ]
NBC friend I don't know if it's an event
related but it seems like it's a since
I've started I see what other young
comics are doing and I've heard like
advice you gave me like similarly like
don't go to the store the improv or the
Laugh Factory until they ask you to go
there is it like because you don't want
like it's the same thing if they came on
here or another podcast they're there
but they might then um they might not be
really ready for ya even no matter how
much you like them we'll always remember
when you go
those big clubs they remember you when
you first start and that's the memory
they have of you in the head right
that's why so many comics a pissed off
locally because they'll start let me
just say I'll just say a city like
Michigan and once the hottest club in
Michigan don't like them they have to
adjust their game they have to leave and
they don't ask for years Jesus Christ
that's my own backyard and they will
give me a [ __ ] and c-spot
because they still remember the night
you went in there and ate a bag of dicks
and then you disappeared and you might
be a bit a little better now and even
though they hear about you stuff you
weren't part of that clique so you get
[ __ ] dick so it's better I think
that's a good way I mean but I don't
like it on the other side of it though
if you'd never asked or if you're not
being assertive how do you get into
places or how do you get on the podcast
honest to god they hear about you people
talked ly I hear names every other
[ __ ] day by accidentally by accident
I'll bump into somebody at 7-eleven and
they'll say they went to the store they
are lame they [ __ ] love the old one
but they couldn't believe Theo was so
[ __ ] funny right yeah or hey-zeus
[ __ ] Trejo I hear his name or you
know when you hear these people you hear
about him you hear that they're making a
wave they're doing something they want
on somebody's podcast and she shaved a
[ __ ] on the podcast they did something
that was true that's not I could see
through what the motion is there's
people who think they're doing things
and they don't know that what they're
trying to do we see it we were there we
were at your level when we were
desperate also I was desperate many a
[ __ ] time but that doesn't mean I'm
gonna call Ben Affleck's mother when I
do a one-woman when I do a one-man show
in Boston to get Ben Affleck to show up
on my show
I know a guy who did that that's yeah
that's it's it when you say it it sounds
crazy but then I don't know I feel bad
for these people sometimes like I feel
bad like how do you maybe you just feel
like you're taking a shot well at some
point mmm
like Rudy has some his podcast before
one of his first visits on this podcast
Rudy Sarzo spoke about a thin line
between musicians and mental health same
thing those were comedians same thing
those are [ __ ] comedians it's a thin
[ __ ] London you've seen it there's
lights you and I have gone out hi the
comedy clubs way before you even
screamed of doing an open mic yeah and I
would go what's the matter you go back
to meeting creeps me out that comedian
creeps me out that comedian couse me out
don't [ __ ] tell me you remember don't
make me say [ __ ] names oh yeah
absolutely rather a couple guys that you
you'll get hired and they would drive
you [ __ ] insane they start running
material or yeah it's crazy and they
don't know that you insane like I'm in
the business now at all smart the [ __ ]
up and it's not their fault it's not
their fault you know I probably did the
same [ __ ] thing but then you learned
that you have to work through strength
not from weakness that's a really weird
sentence yeah what do you mean by that
you have to work from your strengths for
years until about four years ago in the
word got out I would get let's pretend
they're in my space at the beginning of
Facebook I would get hey Joey how are
you big fan of the [ __ ] podcast we
have a proposal for you for you and Joe
Rogan to come do my [ __ ] Christmas
party you know that makes me feel bad
because you really don't want you really
want Joe Rogan but you just don't he's
not replying to you
stupid [ __ ] emails right he then he
thinks isn't good down the line so the
word got out over the years that nobody
plays that [ __ ] so it's time to email
stop
really yeah he got yeah nobody we don't
play there's no reason to play don't
play unless you come direct to me with
something don't come to me for Joyce to
torment people I would love when people
would [ __ ] actually call me and say
can you have Joe's number like oh yes
you're grabbing and and they grab the
pen I'd give them a minute like all
right I like no here it is CAA and I
would give them like whatever the agency
number is and they would just be quiet
on the other end they would just silence
because they thought they were gonna get
a [ __ ] hand out and I just room to
the wolf I thrown directly to the wolf
and they don't even have the balls to
say no no no do you have his number I'm
gonna go listen the best advice for you
I have is to call the agency
you call him personally he's gonna come
over and stab you no one you'll be
walking around like we will bronchitis
from what I'm surprised you didn't like
find a place name like Rogen's hardware
and give them that number or something
just unless it just looks like a fake
number because I'm like I can't I can't
imagine it went on for years I would
wake up to messages from people how much
they [ __ ] love me what can I can I
bring Rogan Whitman's and they throw
some finger at us like some number and
I'm supposed to call Joe and tell him
that I wouldn't even have the heart to
say something like that dog I wouldn't
even have the heart to say something
Alfie is me and Ari do you remember the
guy in San Jose he was gonna do a a
reality show would that squad and he
finally settled with his little
restaurants and Tripoli and then Sam
Tripoli started calling me and telling
me the guy's real the guy couldn't be
real if his life depended on it
he just wanted to do get Joe Rogan on
the stupid [ __ ] podcast or something
what do you guys get lucky emails like
the same day like no we had what
happened was Tripoli told me about the
guy and right there I knew the guy just
went down the totem pole
he went from Rogan he couldn't get a
hold
getting out he went through re re told
to go [ __ ] myself he went through me I
told him I wasn't interested and they go
to Duncan then they go to red band and
red band seems a little interested but
he won't throw Joe Rogan's under the bus
he knows better
so he's kind of lost in it because
without Rogen they don't want rep you
know I'm saying like you really feel
shitty you really get to understand what
people want yeah they don't want you
they don't want you they want rogue they
don't want you they just put smoke up
your ass to try to put a reality show
together or whatever mind [ __ ] they put
their mind I've gotten some of those
even even before the podcast I worked on
Hell's Kitchen once and this girl that I
went to high school with was a chef and
she wanted me to introduce Gordon I was
where I was an assistant editor I never
met Gordon Ramsay but people think I
don't know and just wait and make the
kind of does make you sad - makes you
sad and then when you realize when they
realize that they can't get nothing from
you then there's no more conversation
that makes you even sadder you go wow
that's all you were about you know
that's all you were about he said
something to me
last week you said like anyone who texts
me Happy Easter
oh yeah like you you like Donnie I wish
they wouldn't even text me like you you
can see that that's all they're doing it
for yeah no no no you want to attach
somebody Happy Easter
go [ __ ] yourself if you're not gonna
pick up the [ __ ] phone why he texted
me happy [ __ ] Easter for it's the
weirdest thing when people text you
Merry Christmas
especially when it's like a group text
you like really you're [ __ ] lazy sack
of [ __ ] that's what burns me up about
that stuff but no uh you know when you
go through all these levels as a comic
and even now with the podcast it's it's
hilarious how well I'm gonna go to a
town I'll get three emails from people
to do a podcast that I don't [ __ ]
know like so you want me to get in the
car with a guy that I don't [ __ ] know
if he just smoked meth to go to
somebody's basement to do a
kids cuz you're gonna get me high Wow
why am I so [ __ ] lucky how was I
blessed to get this [ __ ] gift like
you are you [ __ ] serious do you
really think I get in a stranger's
[ __ ] car and go to somebody I've
never even heard of we do what you see
though maybe not podcast but we get in
the stringers no no no no they work at
the club they say no some lose some one
blow yeah I get the [ __ ] car but to
do a podcast I don't know you I don't
know you I don't know your [ __ ]
podcast I don't know I don't know who
you are what do you expect from me if I
don't know who you are what do you
expect from me alright I think these
people maybe they think that they that
they do know you because of the podcast
or maybe they just think they're a good
person like something really weird
happened in Albuquerque that was Brewin
that's the first time well it's happened
before it's happening a different City
before a guy yelled he made a u-turn he
pulled over he pulled up next to me but
I want to put call and set him up then I
talked to him for a couple minutes he
told me his name was a Stefan and I
could just tell the guy had a good heart
he wasn't talking about podcast he
wasn't talking about anything he was
just talking about you merrily I don't
he listens to this podcast in that
podcast and he showed me we'd like to be
to show me he was real he flipped his
[ __ ] badge or weed because I'm real
come on I go you know what
take me to eat some Mexican food then we
drove for like 10 minutes and we talked
about the city and he showed me this and
he showed me that and we went we got
some Mexican food and it was one of the
best days of my [ __ ] life
I gotta be a misfit because yet he knew
who I was but from the podcast but be
eaten won't leave any for me
you just wanted my friendship and I
could tell just from the [ __ ]
beginning but that's it and that's a
gift that a lot of people don't get to
see that I'm real he just wanted my
friendship we went to lunch lunch was
[ __ ] delicious we got back in the car
he rolled another joint we made the
periscope till he drove me back to the
hotel like nothing I couldn't see him
the next day cuz I went to him
Winkeljohn we were gonna get together
and go to a different [ __ ] Mexican
food place but I went to wiggle John's
and I was [ __ ] wiped out I wanted to
give her a good thanks to it the
Winkeljohn and my man Greg Jackson for
taking care of me the guy with the mitts
their podcast I mean what a great time I
had that I met a Puerto Rican kid that
was a fighter there they have dorms
there it was just a real honor to go in
there and just hit the myths for three
[ __ ] rounds cuz I could not breathe
without altitude at all I hit the mitts
I grew some cakes Greg Jackson throw him
taught me how to throw some elbows or
[ __ ] and that was sensational just to
see with that gyms all about they got
everything that I don't think it's open
to the public it just opened to amateur
fighters and real fighters you know that
they have dormitories there Lee they
have apartments there I mean it's the
[ __ ] cool this place you have to have
two doctors on duty there that work on
ya after you [ __ ] hurt yourself and
[ __ ] and it's kind of its kind of gone
to college it's it's tremendous it's
like the Comedy Store of fighting and
your training man weed Greg Jackson like
I look at this schedule alright they
contacted me and said if I would do the
podcast and I was like [ __ ] yeah do the
podcast and when I did the podcast I'm I
go home as well go there and do a
kickboxing class so I looked at the
schedule and they had a class at 10
o'clock well there wasn't a little
kickboxing class I was a ground and
pound class and I'm like listen not for
nothing I'm 55 years old I like to go
and then throw a couple kicks to Jesus
jump on top of the box a couple of
kettlebells
I'll do the circuit training I'll kick
the [ __ ] out of the bag I punch this
[ __ ] up there's no grand mound but
there's no ground and pound uncle Joey's
life I don't want to be on top but I
don't want to be a mother want to be
anywhere and then [ __ ] position I
wanna be the one but now I don't to be
the ref I don't want to know nothing now
I know it's beginning some of the fine
there's nothing another I'm 55
I bent over the punch I might not Bend
back I got three [ __ ] shows sold out
and [ __ ] Albuquerque that can't be
grounded and [ __ ] pounded what are
you crazy that's what people go crazy
take the actors and [ __ ] and Hollywood
people and go to these gyms and they
start [ __ ] boxes I've seen these
actors like in just unfortunate gym that
they were go down there guys you
wouldn't believe it after six weeks
Alston they're [ __ ] Muhammad Ali
their shadow boxing the hit in the mitts
and they're looking at boxers the real
boxes like menacing like look at me I'm
an actor I'll [ __ ] you up
and Justin fortune that [ __ ] god
bless and so every once in a while he
listens to the actor he'll go okay I'll
set something up with you for Thursday
at nine o'clock the actor walks in there
thinking he's [ __ ] gonna do anything
and next thing you know he acting gets
blasted in the head twice with them that
with the edge guard on it's all over
goodnight the guys like Jesus Christ an
open hand out that hard does hitting
pads are you training and kicking the
bag it's been clearly different then
trying to be [ __ ] Joey Monty you
follow me my Joey motsi days a [ __ ]
over well it's kind of crazy
like even going like going back to this
like people with people ask you in this
town I just had my head shots done and
Troy Conrad made me feel like I was a
male model so I can't imagine being an
actor or being someone who's has a
little heat behind them and everything
that they everyone that everyone sees is
oh you're amazing
well first off when those actors get
sent to train like that they get paid
400 500 bucks enough for four hundred
five bucks an hour only and I'll tell
you you look like Hamish woody do you
understand me
for a nickel anomaly I pay whatever the
[ __ ] you want to hear I've never seen
anyone like this you know and everybody
you gotta remember that some of our
trainers listened to you so some of
those Hollywood train is basically
listening to you
you're giving them a nickel and for 15
minutes you're stretching really don't
help me stretching in the next 15
minutes maybe you [ __ ] lift some
weights and then 10 minutes you get a
phone call from your agent that you
absolutely positively have to take
and then you do something some [ __ ]
[ __ ] total raises for ten minutes I
think it's a nickel an hour but there's
people like Brad Pitt there's real
actors that take trainers Keanu Reeves
and they [ __ ] you they work five hours
at that you know they do everything pyro
metrics they're jumping off [ __ ]
boxes then weightlifting that don't
kettlebell this strength training they
get military you know Tom Cruise those
guys are all [ __ ] in you give Tom
Cruise a row watch him even at Tom hatch
or whatever that [ __ ] yeah well they
gained twenty million yeah so you gotta
put ten to six seven eight weeks of
preparation is do it maybe three months
why not if you're gonna make give me 20
million for a [ __ ] movie but at the
end listen to me whether you get in 20
million or whether you get in scale for
the day you get that job you still got
to do the homework but it doesn't vary
like if you got a job for scale would
you lose 50 pounds like would you gain
20 pounds if the role called for it and
I felt it was worth it
I would do whatever I can first off I'm
not one of those actors they wouldn't
come to me one of those method [ __ ]
movies I'm saying like that's they know
who's an actor I'm a ham and Egger I'm
not an actor I just figured out how to
play myself and it's cute and I'd do it
like I'm shooting tomorrow I'm shooting
the Greg Garcia show I guess about the
guest book thank God he gave me a little
roll and like I'm shooting tomorrow I'm
no [ __ ] pro I read the scene 20 times
and even though it's just a few lines
you know I gotta get high and look at
the scene and break it down and see if I
could stretch a line out you know I'm a
pro but I'm still a ham and Egger as an
actor I'm gonna line it all by the
entire well I went back in class for six
weeks and they're [ __ ] now I went back
to class like eight weeks I was like
three different teachers but I finally
realized that the best acting I was
doing was on stage it sharpened up my
[ __ ] my timing acting is timing and
timing is everything
stand-up is timing so your acting
classes helped just end up they all
helped everything they all hoped
everything but what happened
now when I go to an acting class I just
get bored I'm not gonna lie to you I
can't see paying three bills for the
amount of acting that I do per month to
hang out with people very seldom when I
go to those acting classes can I rock
them roll with people they can't rock
them roll with me into the scenes I
already been in big-time scenes and
these are young startup yeah I already
been in big-time scenes gee I don't have
like a I don't know what you'd call
intimidated by Melissa Lee I've been
intimidated by [ __ ] Adam Sandler I've
been intimidated by Robert De Niro I've
been intimidated by a ton of [ __ ]
people you know from Dean Cain to
[ __ ] then I've been intimidated by a
lot I mean you're not gonna intimidate
me brought was in the room with James
Coburn you know how intimidated when I
was but after the first line I started
making eye contact and that's what
acting is all about because you have to
let him know you're in the [ __ ] room
- [ __ ] but it has to transcend
through your eyes your eyes are
everything that's why before you go into
an audition they always tell you to
think of a moment before what the
character you think what the character
was doing with a moment before your
imagination telling you what before he
comes in here to shoot you in the
[ __ ] head was he outside doing
jumping jacks was he in his car saying
goodbye to his daughter was he young
saying so as you're walking up the
stairs what's your thought you have to
go there when you go into an audition
with a scene and I'm just using that as
it could be you walking into a room to
fire somebody it could be a thousand
different okay do you think you're
better at even like just we're gonna
break down acting do you think you're
better at improvising then look a
trained actor is just because of your
stand-up like I think beyond this tier I
always say that I've been doing comedy
since 1991 I didn't really focus on the
writing and the whole art aspect of it
so 93 so reality on paper my first two
years economy with garbage but
something else I learned those two years
why they're not garbage why I have to
count because I was a house and see at
the broker in Boulder and I have a seed
every week for $50 a week and I bombed
pretty much every [ __ ] week so I gave
up on material and I became a men
provider and at that time I started
doing comedy at a black Club called club
mix off these Colfax black night on
Sunday nights you had improvised Lee
so not I improvised till 1997 it got
less and less because down in LA you
can't him advice when there's age of the
room you start talking to the audience
and trying to be cute there's no more
nothing but I mean now yeah I don't know
if you improvise but your your setlist
oh no no no I improvise on stage every
[ __ ] show there's a line that'll come
out whether you like it or not that does
improvised material because when I
started as economy the first six months
I believed that I could be a writer but
I bailed on it and so I what I would do
is get one hook to go into a show and
then I rested on my laurels and then
provides it so my show became 5050 so
let's say you called me up and said Joey
I got a show for you you gotta do 30
even though I know I have 30 I got 18
but I'm gonna improvise for 12 and pray
to God that it all works out well then
however work out though not too many not
too mint a long time improv - that's 12
minutes of improvising so but guess what
Lee one out of every five shows I hit a
home run out of the park with the
improvise and that would convince you to
stick with it and that were convinced me
to stick with it I went to Seattle in 95
and I still because I went to New York
for nine months and then loui in New
York people come out and go how you
doing my name is Lilia had a [ __ ] up
date today
what do you do sir you're a bus driver
you like being a bus driver so that's
the New York humor so when I went to New
York I fell into more that [ __ ]
stupidity humor where you talk to the
audience when I got to Seattle in 95 I
still had that stupidity humor but I'd
talk to in the audience once when things
got dangerous I got into a mode where I
would go into improvising in three
audience and sometimes Dean Dean
sometimes Lee it was [ __ ] phenomenal
but sometimes it was just god-awful
would he do that at open mics too I do
it everywhere I thought in the back of
my mind I was [ __ ] Johnny improvise
for a long time and it got me nowhere
but it did get me material I was gonna
say and it did teach me how to take
chances so if you have you improvised
and found something you liked you run it
down at the end of the night [ __ ] yeah
okay but what I mean improvising also is
talking to the audience
cloud work crowd work crowd work is a
bad habit if you're doing it right now
god bless you and I'm not putting you
down at all but I'll ever like crowd
work and I did it and I did it well but
again it was 50/50 so here I was going
onstage with the set people so let's say
let's pretend that I had 15 minutes I
would have three minutes of material
then I would improvise for three and
then that didn't work I bailed out on
the [ __ ] talking Tony audience hey
[ __ ] Master it seems like a like a coin
toss like because you don't know if
they're gonna say this is what I'm
saying to you I haven't even tried
together this is what I'm saying to you
and you do that so much that your life
sucks I mean there's after a year your
life really sucks
what does it suck because you don't get
nowhere no you're not getting nowhere
because you're scared to actually sit
down and use your [ __ ] pen this is
how it was for me I refuse to sit down
and use my pen then in 96 in Seattle
something came over me and I started
making notes while I was driving
and that was pretty effective notes
while I was driving just little notes so
again I would come up with a joke about
Lee I come up with a joke about King
Kong I come up with a joke about a song
I mean there was no particular order and
I would go up on stage with those two
lines which were funny 50% of the time
60% of the time but the rest of it you
know I'll give you an example when you
drive from the Seattle Yakima Washington
Yakima Washington is considered a Palm
Springs of Washington okay okay I had a
gig there one night and I walk into the
[ __ ] hotel room I lock the door I put
my luggage down I'm happy it [ __ ] it's a
nice hotel well I look in the bed it's
one of those bed that if you put a
quarter in it it shakes
I never even saw yeah this is how young
you are like guys in the seventies the
sixties when you checked into a hotel
room you could put quarters in the
[ __ ] head frame and the bed would
rattle and there was like a it was like
a mini massage that's what it was yeah
it was a sex thing oh my baby even the
sex thing I don't know I was too [ __ ]
young I started in Dumb and Dumber
that's all but I went to this hotel in
Yakima Washington I [ __ ] put the you
know I looked at this bed and I was like
the holy [ __ ] I know let me try it right
put the [ __ ] corner in I put the flat
but the first quarter and it didn't work
and then I bang them a couple times they
you know me being me I put the second
corner and I banged it and finally it
started [ __ ] shaking and it just made
[ __ ] noise like you know I think I
was I don't know what I weighed I
probably was 250 at the time 240 it was
like me with the zip line it was just
too much and that thing kept making
noises it finally [ __ ] up so that
night I remember going up on stage I was
laughing my ass off because I was I and
when I went up on stage and I [ __ ] in
you know it's great to be in Yakima I
went to my hotel room it was a massage
belly and put a quarter in it I woke up
with a thumb in my ass like something
stupidly all because the palm spray I
think that's how bad I was people had so
I'm trying to say to you I had no joke
writing skills but I had a way of saying
something that would hook on to
something and if God was smiling on me
I'd have three tags and then eventually
I would had for years I didn't have Palm
Spring the joke I forget it now I'm not
saying it right something happens I put
a corner in there and I had a thumb up
my ass
that's the Palm Spring of Washington I
don't know bro we all go through a lot
of suffering please forgive me for that
joke but that's just to let you know I
was no [ __ ] Picasso and you got to
stay with it you know which was my man
that for years I had to follow Paul
Mooney in midnight well I wasn't the
seven-year market comedy I became a
regular at The Comedy Store and she
would put me on four nights a week at
12:45 to one o'clock to 1:15 and it was
Halloween you were going up for four
people you couldn't believe you were
finally at the candy store but you
didn't get the mean potatoes in the
audience every night and then she
started liking me met Seashore I was
always around when she was around she
watched me and she'd giggle I was always
down there on Sunday nights I drove the
van by the way happy 46th anniversary to
The Comedy Store without you I'd have no
[ __ ] nothing I'd be in prison right
now so thank God The Comedy Store opened
I was blessed to being a part of it
since 1990 [ __ ] seventh man I'm
really lucky that they made me a regular
cuz lead nothing else would have made me
stay here that was the only thing that
allowed yeah because Jesus Christ it's a
dream to be a regular at The Comedy
Store
nevermind to be inducted by [ __ ]
committee sure that means something yes
that's always been son
to me yeah a lot of things happened in
my life but that's always been something
to me I was a regular at the two [ __ ]
auditions man even Joe Rogan had to be a
[ __ ] unpaid regular for a while guys
she made me a regular right off the bat
- [ __ ] so showcases so far I'm bad
[ __ ] that happened all the bombings I
took all those years they paid off cuz
when I walked in there I had the ten
minutes I needed that would 10 minutes
when I moved from when I left Seattle in
97 I was starting to get it I wasn't
talking to the audience cuz I have come
to Hawaii and I had looked around a few
times and I was given the tour and the
advice if you come down here knock it
off we're talking to people that's the
biggest [ __ ] foot in your mouth here
interesting is that still the case you
know what I would I would still perfect
to it because I don't want to get that
bad habit there's bad habits and things
that you do whether we speak it happens
for me I always go you see what I'm
saying or whatever the [ __ ] stupid sling
I say at the end of my sentences that's
a bad habit when I was a kid I used to
rebound instead of going up with the
rebound I dribbled a ball it was such a
bad habit that the [ __ ] coach told me
every time we do it 25 push-ups and 20
[ __ ] sprints it took me [ __ ] two
months to stop doing it there's little
things that we do the bad habits and
then they become you know biting your
nails and snorting coke you know they
become bad [ __ ] habits but that you
have to [ __ ] correct it and for you
to get better in your field you know I'm
saying what a little field that you want
to excel at I want you not me what
whatever I want you to bury yourself
from time to time when it doesn't matter
and work yourself out of a hole on
purpose then it's hard down because I'm
only doing five minutes most of the time
I want to I want to do great so what you
want to do is you want to go up there
with a topic right and remember because
you and your house writing is completely
different
you have 20 eyeballs staring at you
exactly you follow me me telling you to
give me your money like this and me
telling you with a 45 bazooka in my
[ __ ] hand watch how quick you'll give
me your wallet correct I like her
absolutely so it applies the same to
writing comedy sometimes sometimes it's
good to go on a limb up there just to
test your mind and you may come up with
a [ __ ] jet that changes the whole
thing that came out because it was
supposed to be that you said it it came
out from inside even depression well it
is a weird was one of the worst since I
had ever was earlier this week before I
went up and did Sam's of Tripoli's room
because I was trying to go through it
like a setlist beat by beat and not and
just remember like memorized it rather
than just do it and it was I I had more
of an improvised show I mean I was still
doing the material that I'd written but
I was until I was I wasn't alright ABCD
and it was weird that the more I try to
control it the worse it go sometimes
well here you go in this material in
this one this podcast doesn't apply to
just comedians this applies to salesmen
this applies to attorneys this applies
to anybody that we make a living in a
weird weird sort of way you have to
experiment guys play the [ __ ] simple
yeah and you gotta learn what works for
you but guess who pushes you in your
career it's not your boss it's not your
mom because you know you're the first
generation immigrant it's gotta be you
so sometimes you have to put yourself in
an awkward position you know I may have
to do something tomorrow at 10:00 in the
morning right never college college what
do you think B what do you think you got
a cop much for to teach other the crap
you think they want to teach you how to
cram cramming is something that if you
get good at in your life and you know
how to handle your life will be great
because you know what cram
I'm just doing all one's lacking of
organization right it doesn't take two
your third semester in high school or
your sophomore year I got it my
eighth-grade year when after I got left
back hello it was too [ __ ] late so
basically you go to a [ __ ] class you
take notes you listen to the teacher
okay
you do the assignments and every week if
you knew this going in you would go over
the material wouldn't you wait yeah
every Friday and Saturday instead of
[ __ ] around for now watching TV and
hang out with your friends if you went
over that material on Saturday and
Sunday when the qualities came it would
be a lot easier for you you didn't have
to go back and start from scratch like I
mama look at the a and study all over
again but you took me he is it took me
getting left back to figure that like
that
well guess what the same thing works for
comedy cramming is comedy sometimes Joey
what the [ __ ] you talking about cramming
sometimes is going onstage yourself and
pushing yourself to the limit forcing
yourself to do something taking a chance
you know what I don't want to do this
tonight the fourth wall I'm gonna go to
this 11 o'clock and make my life a
nightmare from time to time I want you
to go to a bar that you know they're not
gonna laugh at I want you to have that
bar and share a [ __ ] even if they throw
bottle on it because you're not funny I
want you to make sure you go back there
the next week because that's the essence
of anything is to no matter what happens
you have to overcome a mentally and it
takes a lot a hand out the musicians and
you know we're not gonna be perfect it's
hard to get over them and not one thing
I do great every time but I'm
disappointed when I don't and I
absolutely disappointed and you know
what you should be but you shouldn't be
how's that for you is that the most
[ __ ] up feeling in the world that you
should be but you shouldn't be
do you like what the [ __ ] are you saying
[ __ ] oh you should be sad that you're
bummed but you should be proud that you
went up and that pride is what takes you
into that next set that next set is the
crucial one because if there's a God
above right everything looks out guess
what's gonna happen you're gonna do well
you're gonna Bob again oh yeah but this
happens with tests
this happens with sales proposals this
happens in construction when you put
bids in you're gonna Bob again oh yeah
absolutely and guess what if there's a
God above and you catch the five o'clock
what's the pizza place you go to Mont
pizza' let's say you go to more pizza
you through the five o'clock guess what
you'll probably eat a bag of dicks again
but now you'll get so frustrated and
then you go to the fourth wall you'll
look over your paperwork you'll make
modifications you listen to all your
tapes because I know you tape all your
sets and you'll switch it around and you
figure it out and then once you figure
it out and you take a chance that's when
you get the rewards
that's when now the next three sets are
brilliant because you changed it around
you renovated yourself you got it
in the arts you got to keep reinventing
yourself if that that's not even a
[ __ ] questionable thing that's a
that's constantly I'm not I don't live
stressed out I don't live you know life
with a gun to my head I think it's hard
for me to write materially by the way
your tag is really working on that bit
about sucking dick out the stars Lee's
are great but we could take a bit and
really add to it that's his gift right
now he and he also has great ideas like
the night I heard him tell the story
listen this is what America wants to
hear Lee already at level one was
telling you what America wants to hear
on The Tonight Show that you know what
you really love your parents
but there's sometimes you don't want to
answer the [ __ ] phone
you know that's number one Jesus Christ
and I don't have parents but I know how
people feel because I might get parent
when I get your number I call you like
your parent and you must go this mother
[ __ ]
this [ __ ] guy's gotta call me at 2:00
in the morning you know I'm saying and
then he told the joke about picking up
his father at the airport like come on
people you're living wherever the [ __ ]
you live is you got enough problems you
got kids and laying a big new dad up at
the [ __ ] that for ya you happy to see
Dad but then he gets in the car and he
gives you the beat he tells you about
your life and right away you do want to
make a u-turn and take him right back to
the [ __ ] Airport those two things
really made me laugh he got rid of him
he got rid of him does he got smarter
than that he should take those two jokes
and ride them til somebody tells Conan
that he says those two jugs there's a
little Jew kid that says every time his
mom calls him that he's got a [ __ ]
look at the phone and go what now I'm
saying like I don't know what you said
it was so honnest and it was true but
guess what happened you started writing
jokes yeah I haven't done those for a
while you think I don't pay attention I
pay attention to [ __ ] everything and
when I go to those [ __ ] fourth walls
I learn like a [ __ ] I even though
I've been doing godly 27 years I leave
they're going Jesus Christ
Lee has no idea what jokes he said
tonight those are Tonight Show jokes
with a [ __ ] sensational delivery if I
had parents I would he gave me a
thousand dollars because I want to roll
the whole special about that especially
if I was Jewish leave take a GNote and
you're my road manager for you what are
you talking about I just want to be an
open mind shut shut up you're going on
the road you're doing ten minutes and
you gonna keep writing every [ __ ]
week because you wrote two jokes to the
brilliant that American never wants to
talk about everybody loves their mother
but Jesus Christ on the third call and
it's not even lunchtime you're like what
now what now what the [ __ ] you know and
he said it either to say that excitable
because it's not what he had and then
you know to say those two jokes
I like his time and paid time on
you tapped into something look at he's
all red now in the face because that's
what you do when you're a comic you sit
back there you shut your mouth you
absorb and you take a piece of very
comic you don't take that material right
you look at where they're going you go
wow I gotta start taking my jokes there
it's a weird concept and it is scary I
don't want to steal so that I've done
weird can never steal
how about Matthew Phil eco Jimmy shelter
flow combat lots muddy clam bait
Nathan start front row Brian always
around my new buddy and step on from new
Albuquerque I love your [ __ ]
I'm sorry I didn't see you saturday Late
Show with Titan I got your number don't
worry about nothing
Chris Trent and Sandra Malta love love
Keough
don't forget son Saturday night me and
Lee
alright the ice house 7:30 show there's
a few tickets left and all that's left
for Columbus is 419 the Thursday guys
I'm sorry I'm not gonna head shows
because I think I'm shooting [ __ ] now
that show that week for Showtime so
tomorrow was shooting the guest book and
I'm doing another episode of the guest
book and I'm doing this whatever and I
appreciate you guys because you guys
have been kept keeping me tip-top shape
you following me ever since I got you
guys in my life I got a [ __ ] walk the
walk I just can't come up here and talk
[ __ ] to you people there was some
man Italian but I can't remember and
that's why like ever since I started
going to the fourth wall when I go to
flower growing others bother flappers
she tells me to get their [ __ ] lying
dirty that means I'm not going up to
1015 I go at 9:15 and I sit in the back
and get a water and I just watch
comedians and I learned I go when I do
that when I didn't do that he's talking
to the audience he's talking too much to
the audience sometimes but Lee I also
want you to react to the audience okay
if a waitress walks
to the things she falls over with a bag
of drinks you just can't keep doing
jokes right you got a crack a joke
that's classy maybe make a movement to
help her pick up the stuff do you follow
me and then get back on stage and start
all over again that takes a complete
different [ __ ] animal
so I also want you to be live and in the
moment and this is why Paul Mooney will
always say you have to get entertained
to be a good entertainer you have to be
it you have to get entertained to write
well I'm having a hard time writing I
will always try to watch a movie but few
years there's been something missing and
I didn't realize what it was till last
Tuesday night when Dean invited me to be
part of his [ __ ] little shunned LR
there then I needed live music back in
my life you enjoyed that much I enjoyed
the energy and I enjoyed the learning
when I was a kid legacy Judas Priest
I always knew Glenn Tipton was a better
guitar planning KK darling KK darling
did leads but I was always a growing
Tipton guy but KK darling was a
performer he shook his head he danced
you find out the different aspects of
selling the show which is what a
comedian does we saw the show the most
brilliant conversation I ever heard
about a comedian the first time I
haven't tapped my back about being a
comedian was when I saw Roseanne on
Larry King Live and they interviewed her
and they asked her about what she fired
her staff why she did that that year as
she goes because I broke comedians it
because comedians we do everything we
produce we write we direct we run the
lights we know exactly how to do
everything we just get [ __ ] lazy once
you use every weapon that you get along
the way this is why I say to you Lee and
I say to a lot of people that yes give
comedy to try give being a guitar player
try if you want to play on our mana
gonna ban go for it whatever the [ __ ]
you want to do go for it because it may
not work out
it may lead you to the road that you end
up on and become a millionaire that'll
be great
I already have the podcast game right
you already know the ups and downs in
the podcast game you see how we
advertise you see how we do this you see
how we do the periscope now you know we
haven't what promoting the product we're
learning so much by doing this job I've
learned a complete different world but I
did not know existed until the last
seven years did I read a book Lee no we
got up at six in the morning into the
podcast twice a week and we learned a
lot from that that we moved on to the
afternoon we learned we didn't get guest
to come in on Cory at 6:00 in the
morning unless they one of these ghosts
you learned so many [ __ ] aspects but
if you don't try you're not gonna wear
it
hell I didn't take you to the road that
you need to [ __ ] be on how do I know
because I'm living it right now I'm
seeing this right now Jesus Christ you
think I saw this 20 years I didn't see
this you want me to tell you when I go
to Santa Fe and three shows are sold
down Albuquerque at the beautiful Santa
Ana casino but I'm gonna [ __ ] tell
you that I knew this was in the cards
for me not at all not at all not at all
not at all did I tell you podcasting was
comin gonna come along predicted it not
at all
but this is the road it took me time I
would've known if I didn't get off the
couch that June 18th of 1991 well and it
was the same injection you're shot which
right now
you get out there you're out that three
shows whether it's the fourth wall the
Carnegie Hall you're still out there
doing the [ __ ] shell so just because
you eat a bag of dicks
there's always a side story to this note
that you're getting something from this
you're gonna remember 20 years from now
every time you go get so that says
7-eleven on a lottery ticket you don't
look at that fourth wall I know [ __ ]
that building means a lot to me even
though now it's a [ __ ] Russian
and school right whatever it is the
sushi plays burnt down yeah thank God
but no that's to really the point I
wanted to talk about today is how I'm
adding I think I'm taking my wife on a
date Friday night and I'm gonna take it
adjust to a random place to watch beer
it doesn't matter what type of gentleman
is when I was a kid I watched from Kenny
Rogers to Judas Priest the [ __ ] yes
so why don't I do it again if it's gonna
help my comedy I can't tell you how much
help I've gotten just from one of the
fourth wall and then how about going to
the fourth wall and sitting there and
watching eight guys doing five minutes
and then I get in my car and I go to a
comedy straw and I see the LIA run white
Rogen and then I gotta go up on stage
think about my [ __ ] world why I have
anxiety [ __ ] but I put myself through
that because at both [ __ ] ends of the
spectrum I learn something so do you
think you might try to learn an
instrument or you think just going and
watching live would be good oh I think
I'm just gonna go watch and entertain it
and live it again you go to a concert
you sit on the side and you start
looking around and you figure out what
this music means to people it's the
weirdest [ __ ] thing me and Felicia
was standing at and I saw a guy with
long hair people that was if you can't
watch the YouTube Leah sure he was
mobile his head like this he wouldn't
stop for the state would only stop for
the songs and then he would start again
and his head would shake and Felicia
looks over she goes I bet he's gonna
have a headache in the morning you know
whatever the [ __ ] she said to me but it
didn't matter that's what I have music
meant to him it didn't have to be ac/dc
anybody could have been playing it
that's what that music meant to him you
look around and you start looking and
now I learned that when I'm on stage
what the [ __ ] I'm saying is affecting
them that's why I took that night from
now I was a blown away I went home I
couldn't fall asleep I had to pick my
wife up the next morning in the airport
I
fall asleep till 2:00 in the morning I
took the guy but gap in the melatonin I
took a half a xanax I company hired I
was scared to take the whole thing I
won't wake up nothing I couldn't fall
asleep because I was so overwhelmed from
a live experience so I appreciate you
guys when you come to a [ __ ] show
because now I know even Thursday night
now I'ma querque I had a rough set my
two shows Friday night were [ __ ]
sensational but there is another upset
because I wasn't selling it I had
forgotten what I was there for I think
the am playing something too real the
[ __ ] and I don't know what threw me
the [ __ ] off it was still a great
weekend I had a great time at Santa Fe
casino and everybody I had contact with
were very sweet the girls are very sweet
and it was just a great weekend but no I
hope you are got something from this
podcast today cuz I think I wanted to
talk about this not basically the
[ __ ] people Facebook the means [ __ ]
but I wanted to talk about the [ __ ]
the comedy and what you're doing right
now in your life that really is the same
plan that we had it seems better for Lee
because he's doing comedy and he's
understanding him more but always push
yourself and put yourself in weird
situations what do you got to lose I'd
rather you put yourself in a bad
situation than a boss make you do
something and you don't know it at least
now you understand the grass for that
situation you ever work at a place like
that there was different levels and
different promotions brain yeah let's
say you started out for example like you
know like I started at the puddle
carwash that's a [ __ ] card dry ok
alright but I would always talk to the
general manager was like kissing his ass
no he was from Philly a Sunday and I
always talked to him during the breaks
this [ __ ] like that and he asked me if I
could sell stuff and one day while I was
drying cars on the snow I went over with
him and he showed me this hosting gig
and then shortly after that I got a job
the body shop you know as a [ __ ] as a
shagger and I was good at it I was a
good shagger
I finally got promoted to be the
detailer was just commissioned which was
pretty good I'm done talking 1987 I'm uh
I'm 24 years old
you know I'm a [ __ ] loser I don't
have a GED yet this is pre-chat napping
you know and when I was a shagger
I was already detailing cars I just
wasn't the detailer my pet but it didn't
matter to me because I was still
learning what to do if you just went
from shaggy to detailing it was like a
three week money contingency that you
would lose money like a [ __ ] I
already lost the money when they would
say who prepped that caught in those
days we will prep them off the ship okay
when you prep a car off the ship it's
completely different it has like
cosmoline on it it may be different
today and all the seats are wrapped you
got to do all that [ __ ] you're gonna
screw in the mirrors and there's a lot
of [ __ ] you got to do when a car comes
off this ship it's just don't come off
looking like [ __ ] Johnny forever
there's a thousand things you got to do
the cosmoline was the worst because you
had a sprayer and chemical on it let it
sit for six or seven minutes then rub it
out [ __ ] good wash it wash it again do
another coating wash it again then you
gotta give it a quick hand wax and they
would pay you like 24 bucks you were a
subcontractor freeze car for each car
was like 24 [ __ ] 24 for new cars and
55 for used cars they got $149 for the
detail you got fifty five bucks but if
you could detail three [ __ ] cars on
one day you didn't do bad there's that
possible oh yeah
I acted detailed three [ __ ] cars on
one day and Tulu was well if I knew that
there was a bunch of new cars I get
there at 6:00 in the morning and I'd
stand get two or three new cars and then
I get to use ones and I'd [ __ ] work
on track
I never what my point is
always learned to do the job above me
not cuz I wanted to steal that guy's job
because I wanted to be prepared when
they all fit is that the way that's
[ __ ] way of thinking father you have
age that's how I thought at that age I
always wanted a no lease job I wanted to
know
Sam tripolis job you know if Sam Triple
E was your boss I wanted to know his job
and I want to know what his job was
because in my mind I wanted to take the
steps and it made all that [ __ ] a lot
easier
I never even that makes sense I mean I
the only places I worked like that were
like at the movie theater and I got
promoted once too from a red shirt to a
blue shirt but other than that no I mean
when you come out when I came out here
to be an editor there's a path but and I
guess you're right cuz I would sit and I
would I would help my friend at it or I
would take editing gigs from for less
money just to like learn you're right so
I guess when you take it seriously it's
like that's like a way to look good and
I'm Prentiss Chapelle moment yeah nobody
cut the corners for you people just do
the [ __ ] work and only will you feel
better about yourself you know they
can't take it away from you that's why I
get frustrated with those [ __ ] emails
just do the work there's no [ __ ]
shortcuts I'm out here with 20 guys that
took shortcuts and they're in [ __ ]
limbo there's the the only shortcut is
the straight line between you and that
[ __ ] go that's it
listen like I said or you had available
is for 19 in Columbus it's a Thursday
night show at 8:30 and there's a few
tickets left for Saturday night working
out I got a couple of bits I gotta
[ __ ] tighten up and you guys are
gonna be my [ __ ] guinea pig 7:30 show
I got a few people going up for that and
that's it for right now man I'm happy
you guys tuned in we got a great podcast
this week the next 405 gets the [ __ ]
savages so I just wanted to get you guys
ready
we haven't done a little school one in a
while I know a lot of people ask me for
him so bad there you have it my main man
Lee I know he's got bronchitis he came
off half a [ __ ] then he with the Jew
cough drop even came with
with the [ __ ] date I'm like well like
he's tired oppressed me if he was a real
gangsta show up with the night night
night when the xxx one that kills bugs
that kills [ __ ] hand jobs from
Chinese people that's the one you
company comes in money with the orange
one at a time and then he wouldn't take
the [ __ ] had a ball or even kind of a
deal and he's got he had bronchitis
three months ago I didn't really call me
the first thing he said to me was I know
guys I can't go to the gym for a week I
don't like this [ __ ] sack of [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] trying to [ __ ] me but
then he's got bronchitis he won't do a
[ __ ] bong a ruski I don't know why
but that don't matter anyway who gives a
[ __ ] all that matters is you
[ __ ] thank you for listening
I'll see you guys Wednesday tim-tom ago
number one like I said in the beginning
listen Fuji Sports has been around since
Jesus left Chicago night trying to call
Fuji baby named after [ __ ] Mount Fuji
anything you need you get you the
[ __ ] leg things for Muay Thai shorts
Agee which I highly [ __ ] recommend
that I will highly highly recommend the
Saporito go the extra 20 and live like a
doctor go to Fuji sports.com right now
you find something you like press in
church and get 10% off how's that one
for you and you know me I'll until the
end they've been with us since day one
or he was here his book came out take a
look at it he's a [ __ ] lunatic but
he's a good man
gonna haunt it right now even though I
finally tasted the Mexican chocolate yes
it is it's [ __ ] delicious the new
milkshake it's a little bigger container
go for it to protein I got the Alpha
brain you know me the new mood the
shroom tech sport the shroom tech immune
they got some tremendous jerky
listen konohana dot-com right now and
press in church and take a look at all
the great supplement a god I can't take
care with the metals in the polls but as
far as the [ __ ] supplements I got you
you know why cuz that's a type of
[ __ ] than I am
listen I love you guys I'll see you guys
Wednesday have a great [ __ ] day today
and remember next Thursday night the 19
me and Kate Quigley
that's all that's left and I'm not
adding to shows I'm too old and I'm
gonna have to shoot that [ __ ] show
I'm dying up here so I'm gonna be too
tired I want to get you guys fresh
tip-top Magoo and ready to [ __ ] go
have a great Monday stay black take that
meal Lee
[Music]